[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  good morning  today as my talk it is the morning of my  talk we just got ready we're about to  head to the venue I just I ran through  my talk once earlier and I feel pretty  good about it  even though I completely missed an  entire part my talk isn't until like  5:30 it's not for a while so I'm talking  to me there's a little table  [Music]  it's got a nervous about me giving a  talk why it was question yes sorry what  was the question  yeah thank you there's one hour until my  talk I'm  [Music]  I'm just reading through my slides  there's one hour until my talk and I  think I'm going to explode and die  either now or on stage  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  yeah  what's going on this I mean there's  workshops tomorrow you're done  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]